maintaining our languages
[Music]
hi steve kaufman here and this evening
i'm going to talk about
maintaining our languages
now uh i often get asked the question
how do i maintain my languages
you know i learn so many languages
more or less up to 21 i don't know them
all equally well obviously
uh how do i maintain them so that's what
i'm going to talk about
uh please subscribe to my channel if you
like these videos
uh click on the bell to get
notifications and please do come and
join me at link
so the question i get often i get asked
very often is how do i maintain my
languages
i guess the simple answer is that i
don't i don't really
think about it i don't worry about it i
know
that i have you know lost a lot
in languages you know my weaker
languages
you know maybe the top 10 or 12 i don't
lose that much
but uh you know romanian czech greek
polish korean you know
uh i've fallen off quite a bit
this evening my wife was watching a
movie on netflix and it was in polish
so i thought i'd go and see what i could
understand very difficult
some bits of conversation i could pick
up especially if they were speaking sort
of more
formally uh you know there was a scene
where this guy was talking to a lawyer
and
there i can understand more of it but
when it's just a quick casual back and
forth
very difficult and certainly i'm nowhere
near
as good as not that i ever was very good
but
nowhere near as good as i was so then
the question and the same can be said
obviously for romanian i
was speaking romanian when i was in
romania but now no way
i noticed my turkish has fallen off my
persian for sure
greek so then the question is well why
bother why
you know invest so much effort and time
in learning these languages when
inevitably when you can't you don't have
enough time to to maintain them to
continue to improve in them and they
they do decline why bother so it
suddenly
dawned on me that every one of these
languages that i have
you know put a lot of effort into
they're like an investment
they're like a field somewhere that i
have
sown uh with with seed you know
and i kind of leave it there and any one
of these
any of these investments or any of these
you know little treasures that i have
i can go there whenever i want to and
kind of fertilize it and water it and
bring it back to life
and you know i know from experience that
when i go back to a language that i put
a lot of effort into
then i don't start obviously at the
beginning and in fact as i go over some
of the material that i did before
i end up very quickly you know further
ahead
and and whatever we forget and relearn
in a way we learn it better
and so to me i have polish there
and one day i hope to have the
opportunity to go back to polish
and it might be before a trip to poland
but i've i've planted that out there
that's something that i have that's
that's a you know an investment that
i've made that's an
asset that i have and the same is true
of greek and romanian
any of these languages so i don't really
worry about
maintaining them so much it's rather a
matter of
if i feel i'm going to you know be able
to use them and enjoy them for a
you know a period of months or whatever
or in preparation for a trip
then i'll be able to go back to them and
the fact that
the casual encounter if i run into
someone who's polish speaking or czech
speaking or greeks keep speaking
and i struggle and can't really say much
yeah
that's unfortunately that's a
consequence of learning so many
languages
not being able to maintain them all at
sort of a an immediately usable level
but on on the positive side these are
assets that i have
that i can go back to whenever i need
them
or want to so i just thought of that in
in light of having you know watch this
polish movie and realized how much my
polish has
slipped but not really feeling badly
about it
because i still have that polish that i
can go back to
so thank you for listening bye for now
oh and i almost forgot on tuesday
at 10 a.m pacific standard time
vancouver time
i'm having an arabic language live
stream
so if you're interested please come uh
check the description box for
you know how to find it we're only going
to have it's all going to be in arabic
um
[Music]
um
bye
[Music]